so who's my guest this week it is the
former national security adviser to
president trump and the former u.s
ambassador to the united nations john
bolton
reagan the two bushes then donald trump
fewer people have had a better seat to
the changing face of the republican
party
since the 80s bolton has been a hawkish
influence in the party's foreign policy
circles
over time he has gone from background
bureaucrat to a more visible presence
loyally serving former president george
w bush and later joining the trump
administration he
made some very big mistakes
when he talked about the libyan model
for kim jong-un that was not a good
statement to make but he's
somebody that i actually had a very good
relationship with but he wasn't getting
along with people in the administration
that i consider very important
bolton's tell-all memoir released in
2020 showed disdain for his colleagues
in the administration
but his failure to testify before the
house committee during trump's
impeachment has led to criticism that he
was silent when it mattered most
he tells me why he thinks president
biden has failed the ukrainian people he
recalls a meeting he had with putin and
why he has zero regrets about not
testifying against his former boss
president trump if your previous boss
president trump was in charge at the
moment where do you think we would be
right now i think the russian forces
would be in kiev by now but but saying
trump is deficient is is is an easy
thing to do i do it quite frequently the
real problem is you've only got one
president
at a time and we are in a situation now
where we have the perception in europe
and in much of congress that the
leadership is weak that it's being
dragged along
uh as events unfold rather than really
trying to shape
the overall environment
thank you very much for joining me today
it's very good to talk to you
i wanted to begin by talking about
foreign policy america's foreign policy
because president biden talked about
being back on the international
diplomatic stage after the trump years
it's safe to say you're no fan of
president trump is the foreign policy
now better than what america had
directly before well it's uh it's like
being asked to judge a harmonica concert
really i mean the the biden approach is
very different than trump's uh biden has
thought about foreign policy extensively
over a long career
uh but in many respects his conclusions
are wrong so it's the difference between
somebody pursuing a generally
incorrect line in foreign policy
compared to another president who had no
line at all in the sense though of where
we are specifically with ukraine do you
feel he is getting that right
not not well enough uh and you know as
they as the saying goes close is only
good in horseshoes i don't think that
the nato alliance is as united as he
says it is uh i don't think uh the
response is effective and and the
greatest tragedy of all the biggest
failure of failure we live through every
day
uh is the failure to deter the russian
invasion to begin with so when when you
look at it from that perspective uh
there there's a lot of rhetoric uh that
makes people feel warm and fuzzy uh but
it didn't translate into an effective
policy and uh it's still not translating
into an effective way well forgive me
though but there's a lot of money that's
been spent of them well wait a minute
let me
forgive me
people say well we've committed x
billion dollars or we're pledged to give
this weapon system this is government
talk this is the talk of inputs
uh the question particularly in a war is
outputs and we can certainly say that
the ukrainian army has fought bravely
and quite well
but the issue now is whether all of the
rhetoric all of the commitments
that different nato members have made
are actually translated into reality and
and that remains to be seen but but in
terms of the money that has been spent
at the time we're talking it's 3.65
billion for weapon transfers and sales
to ukraine
do you believe that 3.6 billion of
weapons have crossed the ukrainian
frontier and are now in ukraine i have
no answer to that or no expertise but
that's the point isn't it
we're in a race for time uh russia's
military performance has been appalling
and the point that we're at now
is whether we get weapons and munitions
to the ukrainian army before putin and
the russians can regroup
and achieve their objectives and that
that remains to be seen but what on what
basis do you not believe that that sort
of support has actually got there that's
what i'm trying to understand well among
other reasons because that's what the
ukrainians say and because that's the
way government works it's very easy for
political leaders to make commitments
it's quite another thing to deliver them
to the troops in the front lines when
somebody says we've delivered 3.2
billion dollars you yourself confess you
don't know where that the the resources
that were to be purchased with that
money where they are are they in poland
or are they in ukraine i suppose what i
wanted to understand is do you think at
the moment then if that hasn't got there
if all that money and all that weaponry
hasn't got there what else do you think
america should be doing well i think
the the
question of giving resources to ukraine
has to depend fundamentally on what the
strategic objective is
and i don't think after having failed
tragically catastrophically
failed to deter the russian invasion
it has not been at all clear what the
american or nato's strategic objective
is
i think it should have been
for ukraine to win the war
i think it was a mistake to
believe clearly we we made intelligence
mistakes just as the russians did about
what the outcome and the opening weeks
of the war would be
uh but there has been really no
replacement for a strategic objective we
should be working toward and i think
without that
uh whatever the level of effort uh it's
it's it's not likely to be sufficient to
achieve
an outcome that will deter the russians
in the future and deter others because
china in particular is watching what's
happening in ukraine very carefully
and adjusting their policies along their
periphery in the indo-pacific
accordingly so lack of strategic focus
lack of delivery on rhetoric uh on the
weapons front and and lack of delivery
on the sanctions front too do you want
boots on the ground do you want american
boots in that i i think we've passed the
point where that's possible so the
question is for example when will
germany austria italy the netherlands
cease their reliance on russian oil and
gas right now
people estimate the cost of the war
is to russia is being exceeded by the
cost of european payments to russia in
hard currency for the continued delivery
of energy supplies
so that on net
putin is still making a profit off this
war i don't consider that to be an
example of allied unity it's gone past
the point of a military intervention as
you see it given that joe biden is
president i think this has been a a
failure of american leadership in many
respects what we've seen is a continual
modification of the american position uh
getting stronger and stronger would you
have supported boots on the ground at
the beginning
i would have long before this supported
putting uh more americans and nato
forces on the ground to train and assist
ukrainian forces
so that russian generals looking through
their field glasses across the border
would have seen a lot of american flags
and wondered what it meant instead in
early december
biden without anything in exchange from
the russians on his own
ruled out
the use of american troops he didn't
have to do that that was an unforced
error that allowed putin to check that
off his list what biden could have done
instead could have done two things one
he just could have remained silent
or he could have said
that all options were on the table and
in both of these other options
it would have put the burden of
ambiguity on putin
left him something to worry about added
to the potential deterrence but instead
by taking it off the table biden took it
out of the deterrence calculator even if
you accept some of those missteps
regardless of where you are on the
political divide
there are many who feel uncomfortable
about boots on the ground because of the
escalation that they fear with russia
if your previous boss president trump
for whom you were national security
adviser of course was in charge at the
moment where do you think we would be
right now i think the russian forces
would be in kiev by now but but saying
trump is deficient is is is an easy
thing to do i do it quite frequently the
the real problem is you've only got one
president
at a time uh and and we are in a
situation now where we have the
perception in europe and in much of
congress that the leadership is weak
that it's being dragged along
uh as events unfold rather than really
trying to shape the overall environment
had there been
a more effective effort before
those comments of binds in december we
might have been able to deter the
invasion to begin with that was the
objective and that failure is something
we see now every day but but ironically
whereas nato and the u.s failed to deter
putin we're now being deterred by putin
and i think that the as you said the
fear
of escalation works to putin's advantage
and and what that means in practice is
that ukraine is being ground into the
dust can i just ask about something
that's been said by a former national
security council official alexander
vinman
he said that the january 6th attack on
the capital was a signal to putin to
start preparing to invade ukraine do you
buy that link
no i don't because i don't think in
trump's mind it was anything more
complicated than
trying to prevent the counting of the
electoral college vote and trump was on
his way out of office he went out of
office he was replaced by another
president putin had met biden before he
met him again in europe last summer for
three and a half hours he took biden's
measure
and then he prepared steps to to go to
war so i think it was a calculation in
putin's mind based on the president
sitting in front of him it's only
because there is that concern about that
potential link so it's interesting to
hear your take on it with regards to
putin let me let me be clear let me be
clear trump's not smart enough to make
that no computing is looking at it it's
about putin's perception not what trump
did but but that's fine but putin was at
that point looking at a president with
14 days left in office do you think
ukraine will be victorious
well i hope so because i think peace and
security in europe which should be of
highest concern to europeans in the
first instance
will be badly damaged if russia has
military success here i think that's
still very much to be decided i think
their performance to date has been
incredibly uh ineffective
but if at some point putin with a
straight face can declare a military
victory
i think the architecture of europe is is
now in question for a long time to come
and i think putin made it very clear in
2005
what he wanted to do when he said the
breakup of the soviet union was the
greatest geopolitical catastrophe of the
20th century so i think what it says is
to all the
former constituent parts of the soviet
union that that you could be next you've
actually met putin i understand and i
wonder how would you describe him there
are many words being used at the moment
well i think he's uh very cold-blooded i
think he's calculating i think he knows
what russia's interests are and i think
he's uh prepared to do almost anything i
don't buy the argument that putin's got
to screw lose
that's convenient but we shouldn't
personalize this war it's not putin's
war alone large numbers of uh russians
not simply because of propaganda but
because of history think of ukraine and
belarus while we're on the subject is
part of the rodinia part of mother
russia uh and and they want it back it's
not about you know putin it's not about
person it's not about personalizing it's
it's about justice as well and who will
be held to account and how this could
play out or how people want it to play
out i mean he's now been described as a
war criminal by uh joe biden of course
and others there are now leaders also
calling for him to be in the hague
you were instrumental in the us's
withdrawal from the international
criminal court
what is your response to that that he
should be in the hague well i i don't
think anybody should be in the hague
because i think the icc is a
fundamentally lawless and illegitimate
institution i think the remedy here is
what ukrainian prosecutors and
investigators have already started to do
to prepare the basis for
for crimes against uh committed against
the ukrainians over the course of this
war i think i think that's the way to do
it but i think it's important for you to
understand and others who think like you
do
that these threats of war crimes
prosecutions do not deter putin in the
slightest
uh and you can talk about them i'm sure
it makes you feel all warm and fuzzy if
possibilities understand let me finish
now you know it's possible did you stop
personalizing this you have no idea what
i think and you're is
you're making a big mistake in your
understanding of who the adversary is
please don't make a mistake of my
personal views i'm quoting world leaders
and when you say you need to understand
because you think like you do you have
no idea how i think it's not relevant to
the interview what's relevant is i i
think i get a pretty good sense of it
honestly well i like facts so do i
with your
credibility as an advisor former
national security advisor you've held
many roles you've also of course been an
ambassador to the united nations
how much has your credibility been hit
by your decision to put your concerns
about president trump in a book rather
than testify before congress during his
impeachment
well i decided that the the appropriate
thing to do when confronted with the
impeachment investigation which i
thought was doomed to failure
uh was to make myself available on the
same basis as every other witness who
testified
uh pursuant to a subpoena my deputy was
subpoenaed he tried to get a an answer
in litigation when he got an order from
president trump not to testify
and the house of representatives backed
away i was never subpoenaed i offered to
testify to the senate
they decided they didn't want evidence
i did the best i could under the
circumstances and i think the
effort to produce the book to give the
full story of what happened
is is the best thing to have done and i
did it based on
my view of what the right approach was
and uh answer to my own conscience do
you regret it
no it was a it was a difficult uh
decision it was a hard situation
but
but i thought about it as carefully as i
could i tried to do what i thought was
right and i feel comfortable with the
decision it's just because you have
alienated some in your own party many in
your own party of course the other side
will never probably the biggest fans
it's safe to say party politics being
what it is and and you know some on your
own side in the republican side that led
to you being called the thing that i'm
sure you would resist very hard which is
unpatriotic look you can only say to
thine own self be true i did the best i
could see so your version is you weren't
asked you weren't subpoenaed to testify
and then you weren't asked so you didn't
testify so instead you put it in a book
well it's it's much more complicated so
if you want the full story as i said at
the beginning i i saw this impeachment
effort as basically doomed to failure
and it did fail trump was acquitted so
my concern was that in the in the way
the advocates of impeachment were
proceeding
they were dooming themselves to an
outcome where trump would be acquitted
and so
completely the opposite of their
objective to punish trump in the in the
best outcome or at least to constrain
and deter him they achieved exactly the
opposite they emboldened him they
enabled him they allowed him to say i
got away with it once maybe i can get
away with it again i thought the entire
effort was doomed to failure and i
thought the best thing i could do in
those circumstances when they were
guilty of impeachment malpractice as we
can see
in retrospect
to tell the story in its fullest detail
and get it out there and allow people to
read it they can read the book and they
can make up their own mind couldn't you
have done both i i i've done i've been
involved in american politics for a long
time in the entire history of the united
states there's only been one
successful impeachment and it wasn't
even through impeachment but through the
resignation of richard nixon
and the way that occurred
was that
the growing feeling on a bipartisan
basis that nixon had to go the advocates
of impeachment against trump rejected
the possibility of getting
republican sympathy they got a very
limited number of votes no possible way
that they would get to
two-thirds of the votes in the senate
the way they conducted the affair and i
do think that was entirely predictable
right from the get-go i think it's just
people are very uncomfortable with the
idea of somebody profiting from that
sort of uh description as well well look
uh it's a there's a long history of uh
of american officials writing their
memoirs
uh and many people have written their
memoirs of the trump administration both
those for trump and and those against
trump uh and uh uh that that's that's a
very very common it is but there was a
particular context which we've explored
at length do you have guilt having been
president trump's national security
adviser no i don't have a sense of guilt
i took the job with an effort to
enhance american national security i
felt
having heard everything there was to
hear about trump before i took the job
that
nonetheless like every other american
president
that the gravity of the responsibility
the weight of the decisions he would
have to make would discipline him at
least in the national security field
and it turned out i was wrong in that
assessment but the effort that i spent
over 17 months like many others in their
own different positions but but those
efforts were devoted to enhancing
american national security
as i saw it and i don't regret it for a
minute and yet all you have written
about him all you have said about him
even what you've said in this interview
about where the ukrainian war would be
now with the russians in kiev if he was
in charge
you were part of that you were aiding
and abetting that administration that
you so loathe
was that your opinion by the way or were
you just reflecting other opinions when
you said i was aiding and abetting trump
just out of curiosity listen let me let
me explain
working for him yeah that's right so so
you ain't about your boss
the conclusion the conclusion of your
argument is that nobody with any
responsibility should have worked for
trump and i reject that uh i think that
i and i'm not uh speaking for myself
alone because there were hundreds of
people who joined the trump
administration to do the right thing for
the country and i think many of them
were cruelly disappointed at the
behavior of the president
but that
should not sully the efforts that all of
those people made uh on behalf of uh of
public service for the united states and
for the party the republican party i
presume from your perspective you can
you can
that's part of politics you're right
that's part of politics isn't it is
there any country in the world any
democratic society in the world that
you're aware of that doesn't have party
politics i'd like to hear it if that's
uh if that's your view that wasn't an
attack it was a statement that is part
of it you do it because you also love
your political party it's a statement
for philosophy that's correct that's
exactly right and what i was going to
come on to with that is are you now
politically homeless
no i don't think i'm homeless at all i
have a pack a super pac a foundation i'm
actively involved in trying to help
candidates get elected who believe in a
strong u.s foreign policy
i think the influence of trump within
the party is declining significantly i
expect it to continue to decline
and i expect by a return certainly in
the national security field to a
reaganite foreign policy will be a great
success philosophically and for the
country do you think though he will run
again of course 70 million plus
votes huge donations some have a very
opposite view of you of his influence
well a lot a lot of people have a lot of
views i personally don't think trump
will run i think he knows that he
lost in 2020 he won't say it publicly
but i think he knows that he lost
and i think he fears losing in 2024 and
one of the worst things
uh in trump's view is to be called a
loser so i think he will talk
incessantly about running
up until the last minute and then uh he
will announce he's not and he'll try and
be a king maker in
the republican party nomination fight
for 2024. and from your perspective who
is the bright star in the republican
party who who should that go to
well i don't i don't have a preferred
candidate yet i think there's going to
be a very large number of people
contesting for the nomination and uh
i'll i'll watch it as it unfolds okay i
didn't know if you had any early early
people you'd spotted that you wanted to
to flag at this point because i suppose
from what you're saying is you see trump
as an anomaly within the republican
party it can recover and go forward in a
way that you feel you can support it
of course trump is an aberration to use
a star wars metaphor he's a disturbance
in the force this is not anything like
that permanent change well uh finally
would you still get into politics if you
had your time again a lot of people look
at it today and they're they're not
always sure it's the best career they're
not always sure it's the best move for
them and certainly because of social
media a lot of things have got a lot
more toxic i'm sure you've noticed no i
would still do the same thing i think
the most important uh thing that uh
that any american can do really is
continue to protect the security of the
country which which remains in my view
the last best hope of mankind john
bolton thank you very much for talking
to me it was a pleasure and thank you so
much for being with us until we meet
again take care and goodbye
[Music]
you